ثمن باهر توعد ترامب الديمقراطيين بدفعه
بعد صدور نتائج تحقيق جون دوران الرئيس
الامريكي السابق قال ان مدير مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي السابق جيمس
كوميديمقراطيين يجب ان يحاسبوا على قضائهم
سنوات في التحقيق في التواطئ المزعوم بينه
وبين روسيا ياتي ذلك بعد ان اصدر المستشار
الخاص جون دورام تقريرا يقول ان التحقيق
حول علاقه ترامب وروسيا لم يكن ينبغي
اجرائه مطلقا هذه التحقيقات الديمقراطيه
اليساريه المتطرفه هي الاكثر اثاره
للاشمئزاز في تاريخ بلدنا انها وصمه عارك
سيكون الامر مسليا للغايه ولكن سنرى ما
سيحدث اذ اجرى المحققون تحقيقا سياسيا في
خضم انتخابات عام 2016 حول ما اذا كانت
حمله ترامب تواطئت مع روسيا لقلب النتيجه
التقرير انتقد مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي
لفتح تحقيق كامل على اساس معلومات
استخباراتيه خام وغير محلله وغير مؤكده
فالسرعه التي فعل بها ذلك كانت خروجا عن
القاعده كما ذكر التقرير تطورات تاتي بعد
تحقيقات اجريت مع ترامب في منها وربما
ستخدم مصالحه قبيل انتخابات الرئاسه
وصراعه القوي مع الرئيس
الحاليين عموما بلال البجدين العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات